well
[Music]
hello health andrés gonzález today is
friday november 6 and these are the
most important news of the day the
results continue to come out and the gap
continues to grow in favor of the
democratic candidate job airén here in the state of
nevada in anticipation of the  country this
morning the secretary of state published
new numbers in the vote count
expanding the majority for bailén in
nevada while the results in
the states of georgia and pennsylvania
also showed that bardem is
ahead in this reality race
to follow the results of this
lesson visit happens for these
elections in news now dotcom
and in other news the police continue to
investigate a homicide southwest
of the valley of las vegas' detectives have already
indicated that everything points to a case of
self-defense in the incident that
happened around one of  the morning
when a man shot and killed his
roommate
near 215 and sunset street  t according to
agents the man who died was
drugged when he stabbed his
roommate who in self-defense
shot and killed him while the man
stabbed without critical condition at the
university medical center and is expected
to survive
and in new figures in prices  of
homes around the valley and the
news favors
homeowners the report that came out this morning
shows that the median
home sale price for October was $340,000,
this figure exceeds last month's and
shows an increase of  11 percent
more than in October of last year
and the new
Las Vegas football team's riders are in
trouble with the NFL for violations of
coronavirus safety regulations The team was fined half a
million dollars and in addition  Punished
with draft picks The Raiders
were tossed out of their sixth
round draft pick for failure to handle the positive case.
or one of his players and they
also fined their coach jon
gruden for improperly wearing his mask
and some of the shows in the
hotel zone of las vegas 'reopen
tonight in serious gamer shorts seven of
his productions including david's
copperfield left walking wagon among
others all shows have a
limited capacity and in some
cases the shows will be presented in
larger theaters to ensure
social distancing now let's move on
to the weather forecast today
we will have a maximum of 86 degrees and
we will see a  increase in winds and
with the possibility of rain for Saturday
and Sunday with temperatures in the 50s
and 60s so you have to bundle up is
all the information for today I
am at 3 gonzález with your new
information from the isna or at  spanish happy
weekend
[Music]